monsieur le ministre bonjour bonsoir
bienvenue à 24 60
une annonce très importante parce qu'on
est tellement préoccupé par l'urgence
climatique on attend chaque mesure comme
presque un cadeau du ciel qu'est-ce
qu'il y a dans l'annonce d'aujourd'hui
quelque chose de rassurant au poste sur
l'atteinte de nos objectifs est-ce qu'on
va y arriver oui et ce qui frappe
l'imaginaire c'est l'importance des
budgets qui sont maintenant accordés à
la crise climatique c'est un plan de 9
milliards de dollars qu'on annoncé ce
matin si on regarde depuis les deux
dernières années c'est un budget qui est
en croissance de 35%. donc c'est une
première nouvelle mais la meilleure
nouvelle encore c'est qu'on se rapproche
de la teinte de notre cible lorsqu'on
initié notre démarche on avait 42%
identifiés financiers on est passé à 51%
l'année passée on est maintenant 60% ce
qui fait qu'à chaque année il y a une
progression constante qui se fait et on
sera 100% 2000 parce que si on prend le
chiffre d'aujourd'hui qu'on vient de
voir le tableau à l'instant 60% c'est
pas 100% alors comment peut-on y voir la
teinte des objectifs vraiment pour
donner une démarche extrêmement
rigoureuse avant de calculer un
pourcentage on s'assure que trois
éléments réunis la mesure identifiées
avec le la réduction de GES le budget
confirmé donc c'est pas hypothétique le
budget confirmé surtout le changement
réglementaire qui va en conséquence donc
avec ces trois éléments là comme je le
mentionnais on n'est plus possible de 42
à 51 maintenant 60% et c'est une mise à
jour qui est faite à chaque année donc
au printemps l'année prochaine je
reviendrai avec le plan de mise en
oeuvre numéro 4 au supplémentaire
davantage d'argent et surtout des
pourcentages de plus le but c'est d'être
à 100% en 2030 encore une fois on ne
calcule pas les potentiels on calcule
les effets réels donc si nous regard une
rigueur qui nous empêche de
d'extrapoler et on y va avec des
certitudes en même temps vous avez
entendu l'opposition il voit là dedans
des mesures à la petite semaine
c'est pas possible j'allais avec des
mesures très concrètes jusqu'en 2030
c'est des mesures très concrètes en fait
le 9 milliards comprend 180 mesures au
complet au total on est en mesure
d'associer pour chacune de ces
mesures-là des réductions précises de
démission de GS donc ce n'est pas
improvisé ce n'est pas la petite semaine
et c'est appuyé par une réglementation
qui est contraignante aussi et l'année
prochaine on sera en mesure d'ajouter à
ce pourcentage de l'important c'est
d'être à 100% à la fin de dessiner
au moins en fait ce sera moins en fait
plus on se rapproche du 100% plus c'est
des étapes qui sont difficiles donc là
on fait des bonnes 9% moyenne par année
mais avec les années on peut s'attendre
à des bons plus petits mais l'important
c'est l'atteindre la cible en 2030
de l'échéance plus c'est difficile
qu'est-ce qui est plus difficile c'est
d'harmoniser au delà des politiques
c'est la volonté des gens de faire
vraiment quelque chose les individus
d'ajouter des contraintes parce que je
prends l'exemple de voiture électrique
vous en voulez deux millions en 2030
bonus Seigneur alors qu'il y en a pas
j'en ai loin du compte pour le moment
les gens qui achètent une voiture
électrique en ce moment il attend des
fois jusqu'à 18 mois il paye très cher
puis on se demande comment vous allez
atteindre cet objectif bien identifier
la problématique la demande elle est
très élevée mais l'offre est
insuffisante donc on est venu ajouter un
règlement très contraignant pour les
constructeurs pour les obliger à rendre
disponible ces véhicules là et ça va
nous permettre d'atteindre le 2 millions
parce que si jamais il ne les rendent
pas disponibles c'est des contraintes
financières excessivement importantes
qui attendent c'est constructeur là et
ce type de réglementation là là où c'est
implanté à travers le monde c'est là où
les résultats sont les plus probables
une des critiques qui est faite c'est
que les gouvernements le vôtre aussi
hésitent comme ça se en Europe
d'imposer à ma liste sur les voitures
énergivores parce que elles sont très
populaires encore et ça vous le faites
pas c'est pourquoi c'est volontaire on
disait il y a un problème de
disponibilité moi je serais bien mal
avisé mal à l'aise dans d'imposer un
malus alors que l'alternative n'existe
pas c'est difficile de pénaliser
quelqu'un alors que le choix qu'il soit
très faire n'est pas disponible donc on
veut rendre disponible ces véhicules là
dans un premier temps et par la suite le
marché va s'adapter on est les premiers
on parlait de l'Europe avant l'Europe on
a on a adopté une loi qui vient
interdire la bande des véhicules à
essence après 2035 la Californie s'est
collé sur notre propre réglementation
donc on est réellement des leaders au
niveau de l'électrification des
transports
s'intéresse tout le monde on en utilise
encore beaucoup même monsieur Drainville
il dit là je vois que j'ai ça va tout
être des voitures électriques on parlait
du troisième bien mais il reste que
lorsque vous êtes une alternative n'est
pas l'alternative électrique n'est pas
là mais entre s'acheter une voiture très
vieus très énergivore et une voiture
moyenne qui est pas énergivore il y a
quand même il y en a des alternatives et
c'est pas le gouvernement qui peut juger
des besoins des citoyens la première
alternative celle qui privilégie c'est
tout le temps de transport collectif et
dans 9 milliards on a inclut pas les
dizaines de milliards qu'on a
actuellement en transport collectif mais
en même temps c'est moi la personne en a
besoin pour son travail c'est une
famille nombreuse je peux pas dire on
vous confie à des des petites voitures
faut laisser cet espace de liberté là
mais oui il faut viser l'électrification
même des VUS en 2035 ça s'appliquera
également au vus si on a plus en plus de
vie US électrique aussi des modèles
nouveaux qui s'ajoutent année après
année mais c'est pas le gouvernement qui
veut dire vous n'avez pas le droit
d'acheter tel type de véhicule on ne
connaît pas les besoins des gens et on
les laisse prendre décision là qui sont
les meilleurs pour le réel vous pouvez
514 millions pour les bombes de recharge
ça c'est fondamental on veut plus de
véhicules électriques naturellement faut
avoir le réseau pour le supporter donc
c'est un investissement majeur on a déjà
une raison là l'électricité oui ça a été
tous été calculé avec nos partenaires au
teintes au Québec avec mon collègue à
l'économie et l'énergie donc c'est
validé la disponibilité elle est là on
ne peut pas espérer avoir deux millions
de véhicules électriques sans avoir le
réseau de recharge en conséquence déjà
on est les meilleurs en Amérique du Nord
au niveau du réseau de recharge avec ces
5 millions là sans que 100 millions
supplémentaires se réellement hors de
communs hors de comparaison avec les
réseaux qu'on retrouve ailleurs qui est
intéressant aussi six tonnes de CO2 par
habitant c'est un objectif alors qu'on
est à 8.7 comment y arrive c'est
l'édition de toutes ces mesures là c'est
une moyenne par habitant et là où ça on
a toutes les raisons d'être fier au
Québec on a une moyenne de 9 tonnes par
habitant alors que le Canada et les
États-Unis c'est plus que le double donc
on est réellement dans une position de
leadership mais ce 9 tonnes là on veut
l'amener à assistant et c'est en étant
assistant par habitant qu'on aura
atteint notre cible de 37.7 37.5% de
réduction par rapport à l'année de
référence qui est 1986
grande actualité entourant ce fameux
dépotoires vous avez reçu vous allez
recevoir sur une invitation à des
manifester devant le bureau de votre
collègue d'un collègue fédéral Mike Melu
mais écoutons d'abord ce qui s'est dit à
la Chambre des communières entre les
députés blocus monsieur Garon et le
ministre de l'Environnement monsieur
Guilbaud on écoute
de jouer au ping-pong puis qu'il fasse
preuve de leadership en entrevue à
Radio-Canada le ministre des Relations
couronne autochtones tenait ses propos
regrettable et je cite il faut lâcher
cette idée que chaque fois que deux
trois autochtones impliquaient dans un
enjeu que c'est un problème du fédéral
monsieur le Président la communauté
demande de l'aide et c'est une réponse
inacceptable à le rappel au cas demande
de l'aide toute la région demande de
l'aide sur le parti qui fait du
ping-pong avec ce dossier là c'est le
Bloc québécois
j'ai moi-même reconnu hier monsieur le
Président en entrevue avec la presse que
le gouvernement fédéral avait un rôle à
jouer que le gouvernement fédéral allait
jouer son rôle si eux veulent jouer du
ping-pong nous de ce côté-ci de la
Chambre monsieur le Président on va
trouver des solutions
alors cette histoire de Cana sattaquer
de déversement de dépotoires illégal
c'est une bombe environnementale on crie
à l'aide est-ce que on vous lance la
balle qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire
concrètement pour première chose qu'on
devait faire on le fait on le fermer le
site moi je suis en train de fonction en
janvier 2019 c'est un des premiers
dossiers que j'ai eu et malgré les
recours judiciaires des responsables du
site qui ont prolongé les délais en
quelque sorte on a réussi à le faire
fermer en 2020 cependant cependant un
passif environnemental qui est important
on travaille avec mon je travaille avec
mon homologue fédéral mais également au
niveau du Québec mon collègue Yann
Lafrenière responsable des relations
avec les Premières nations avec la
communauté locale aussi d'ailleurs mardi
on a une rencontre importante pour voir
qu'elle pourrait être les suites j'ai
mon collègue à la sécurité publique qui
était interpellé qui est impliqué dans
la vie dans ce fameux laboratoire lié au
crime organisé c'est comme une sorte
d'impuissance et la décontamination
voudrait ça ça coûterait 100 millions on
évalue en dizaines de millions sinon une
centaine de millions là tu es
contamination du site ça c'est un passif
fédéral par contre c'est pas qu'on veut
se dégager de notre responsabilité mais
c'est un passif environnemental fédéral
mais dans l'intervalle il faut cesser la
possibilité qui est une contamination
qui s'accentue donc on continue à suivre
le dossier de prêt il y a des
inspecteurs qui s'y rendent à l'occasion
les inspecteurs fédéraux étaient là le 8
mai dernier ne semblait plus y avoir
d'écoulement vers la rivière ce qui est
déjà une première bonne nouvelle il
semble bien avoir eu une brèche
locataire colmatée donc faut suivre le
dossier de prêt mais ce n'est pas simple
effectivement ça implique plusieurs
ministères autant du côté québécois que
du côté
de fermer le site s'assurer que la
contamination ne se propage pas
maintenant exact et c'est ma région je
suis député du secteur donc c'est un
secteur que je connais bien et c'est de
s'assurer qu'on puisse entreprendre à
des contaminations du site le plus
rapidement possible
on a des rencontres régulières avec nos
homologues fédéraux à ce niveau merci
beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]